[Music]
hey what's up y'all oh
hey what you guys playing oh no just a
little dvd right you know what uh what
dvd uh
it came for you in the mail it says to
my fresh dope son from
m.c mom i can't wait to see it
hey if there's one thing we're gonna do
today we are playing that dvd
come on come on man oh yeah
oh yes oh god please man did you produce
this trap no no no no no no no
i'm the m to the c to the m o m and when
it comes to mom rappers i'm the bigger
the best of them
wow sending out this rhyme to my homie
number one
his name's carl stewart but to me he's
just the sun
word up oh okay she got that running man
down come on can we please turn this off
no
yeah i missed it you left some stuff
behind that i can send you if you need
like your best friend bear and your
magazines
going through all this stuff but it
looks pretty risky you use so much
lotion but your socks sure are crispy
i've been cleaning with the broom and
the vacuum and found victoria's secret
is she's hiding in your room
every nook and cranny there are rods of
tissue i can't even open this swimsuit
issue what is wrong with you bro
i spilled a soda on that magazine i'm
getting your sheets so
nice and clean like when you wet your
bed till you were 16.
i overreacted sorry i spanked you look
another crispy sock
no thank you oh she's sniffing that
is wrong how many crispy socks she gonna
find huh crispy socks here
crispy socks there crispy socks with
some mystery head we're gonna turn it
off right now come on you guys
we started it we gonna finish
[Music]
oh all the bee changed up
i got the kitchen and the basement and
the living room and since your dad met
that [ __ ] i got his office too got my
juices going my rhymes flowing
my breath blowing showing the signs are
slowing i can feel my skills growing
took a little practice to practice these
lyrical gymnastics but now the fact is
queen bee imma be throwing out your
mattress hell yeah
baddest [ __ ] in the biz taking the show
on the road you can clean up your own
chairs
[Music]
peace
ah
[Applause]
12 homes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
penis
[Music]
[Music]
teen face you tend to taint your face is
a day
time time
take it back no i won't take it back
i never will take it back
cause you're the son of a son of a son
of a son of a [ __ ]
you don't need to fight over me
there's plenty
you know what i'm talking about right
y'all know what i'm talking about
[Music]
there's a light and it shines within the
darkness
of the sands of time from time
there's our fight but the battle to be
won is with the man inside
nothing will keep it from
[Music]
like a dream you can never tell the lies
[Music]
is
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
exactly as it seems
[Music]
is believable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is the power of wings
[Music]
would you look at that you should just
stay ahead at night
i've had too much wine you can leave at
first light
it isn't that far maybe just to stay
where you are back to
my place you can't escape from my
embrace
i really had a very nice
[Music]
hey no
[Music]
we can make this harder just easy
woman always comes prepared
[Music]
[ __ ] you are mine tonight
[Music]
please just please go away you wanted me
to stay
well i i just changed my mind i think
i'll just stay and unwind
how did this all switch
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got
[Music]
[Music]
galactic super train
[Music]
supernova spanish harlem
[Music]
gotta
[Music]
wreak disease tickle bees
[Music]
laser currency
hey what the hell are we saying man i
got no idea man i'm just hungry and
talking about the galaxy and trains
i think they buying it though
hi i'm ray parker jr writer and
performer
of the academy award-nominated hit
single
ghostbusters from the major motion
picture
ghostbusters but that's just one song
i've written so many other major motion
picture theme songs
and submitted them throughout the years
now they're available
and together for one specially priced
compilation
songs like you tried to play the game
but it's driving you insane
jumanji danger in the jungle
[Music]
jumanji lying in my house
come on mr computer throw me a bone
i said lawn mower man get up off of my
lawn
when armageddon is near you better get
out of here
look like a big empire i ain't afraid to
know destroyed
watch out behind you that's trying to
find you pelican
brief it's getting legal y'all
these songs have only been heard by the
highest level of industry decision
makers
but now you can feel like a hollywood
executive
in your own home i see your face off
that guy walking around it's a face off
that ain't even your face passing on the
christ
get me down off for this cross passion
of the christ
you know my daddy is the boss to serve
me
now there's a whole lot of kinky bet
that room is stinky
50 shades of grey all right white people
who's a slave i'm not a slave
oh 12 years i say
what
[Music]
there's one thing i know is that
persistence
makes perfection sure hollywood missed
out
but that doesn't mean you have to down
in the basement
what's going on it's uh
there's a kid and a nazi down there
[Music]
order now to receive your free copy of
bobby sings the twos
theme songs to sequels that were never
made
[Music]
[Music]